[Music]
we just arrived in atami it's really
pretty here we're in a Plum Garden with
no
plums what a sneaky spider
you're just walking you could walk right
into that massive
[Music]
thing well you can imagine how pretty it
would be if it was all in blue
[Music]
right so plums bloom a little earlier I
think than Cherry that's probably why
the leaves are already all gone that
makes
sense hello
V you having a good
[Music]
time feel like I can shower right
now my st's over there but I want to
check out what's over
here oh wait you can go in
whoa what I'm behind the
waterfall oh God I can't see anything
where's the
Flash no
way
[Music]
my I can't see
anything I made it out of L thank
God
Ah that's really
[Music]
warm I I got this Plum drink but he said
there was corn in it and I was like what
then now I drink it and it's
like it's really good but it's like the
weirdest drink ever it tastes sweet and
sour corn Plum it's such a weird mix
it's really good and spicy we're going
to go check in to our
Airbnb we should have an onson there as
well I hope at least their spiders are
lurking
everywhere we got the sleeping
baby
it is so cold
outside oh that's hot that's almost too
hot oh yeah feet
reveal this feels so
[Music]
good come
Onan come on
run
hello h
[Music]
day two in at
Tommy we just went to the beach to check
it out it's very bright it was so cold
yesterday now it's like summer
again do you think I can surf these
waves oh do you see that over there is
that the castle on top and there's like
a Shrine no I don't there's a castle I
found
[Music]
it wa there's a lot of
them we're stopping for lunch and they
have it's at a diner where they have the
robots giving you food and I hope the
robots w't give us food they always ask
if you want the dessert first or after
and I'm always like just give it just
give it to me I don't
care is it us
yes Hello
[Music]
Kitty you see the hot water coming
out from all the streets it's kind of
cool we're going we going this way we're
actually um returning you to the police
we're turning you in be for pooping at
the worst times
[Music]
possible they got a monkey show right
now oh it just ended be I swear if I
missed the monkey
show oh it's starting
again hurry the monkey show oh my God it
is
[Music]
[Applause]
monkey you think the monkey liked
it so that's where we were earlier when
we were pointing to the
castle over there you think it's like an
old castle but it's like the most
touristy conversion ever no he's
sleeping it's okay don't drop the baby
this is the chance
[Music]
you're
one that was the best one
easy we all look so
anime first
try
I was
[Music]
joking be's laugh is like an old
man so
[Music]
cute mommy's so funny
all right I was saying we're going to
Ito now it's an hour drive and then
we're staying at a hotel now which is
going to be nice hard traveling with a
baby but it has his moments I guess
right
be
in should be nice are you
excited
[Music]
looks a bit
dated the view is amazing
wow oh my God what is it it's the
world's smallest sauna that I have ever
seen it's just a chair this is the
Nordic
Suite what's Nordic about it no I like
it it's not bad actually traveling with
a baby it's not always easy they have so
much stuff luckily Ridge sent me their
new travel suitcases and this has been
so helpful I'll let you guys know a
little secret actually you've seen me do
Ridge promos before they have the
minimalist uh wallets as an epic
minimalist I just love but Ridge
products are genuinely those things that
I see other YouTubers use even when
they're not promoting it because they're
just that high quality and that good and
this travel SU case and backpack is is
no exception I don't know how to
describe it but they have this cohesive
sort of uh texture to it not just color
but also the feel which is really nice
in the past whenever I would get
suitcases I would just get black ones as
an epic minimalist but you can never
find it amongst everyone else's and I
like that they all have a color that
pops but still looks really stylish the
suitcase is so high quality that is
literally a lifetime warranty it's 30%
thicker while still being lightweight so
this this thing is durable when you have
these luggages the main thing is the
handle right that's what you interacted
with the most and it's super comfortable
much higher quality than any one I've
used got the 360 Wheels spinning like a
bad boy look at it another thing about
rid products is that they're always
really well thought out and well
designed and these are no exception they
have a ton of really useful small
compartments especially with the
suitcase I always feel like I have a lot
of small electronic stuff and I never
know where to put them and I just hide
them in between my socks but this one
comes with a ton of different cases
where you can sort them out smartly and
I I really really like that it also has
a hidden tracker compartment so you can
make sure yours doesn't get lost also
now that we have a baby having a
backpack is just so useful got the soft
compartment here for laptops and tablets
phones easy access for be's
milk that's what they thought about it
there's like one two there there's
something compartment
oh I forgot to mention they're all
weatherproof but yeah genuinely really
proud to promote this product I think
it's really good they let you try it out
for 99 days for free and if it's not for
you that's okay but they know you're
going to like it and I I can testify as
well and anyone ordering the luggage
using my link will get a free travel
case as well so use the link in the
description and thank you Rich for
sponsoring this
video
[Music]
I'm coming to invite
you
what did you do to your sweater be look
where V
are the teddy bear Museum the reason we
went on this
trip you think so
yay
wow it's Mama looks so
[Music]
cursed
so that's how you were
be got
it
[Music]
we're going to go somewhere now but bejn
is sleeping so we're going to let him
nap a
bit there were too many Teddy
beers we are going to check out the
seaside no the cliff side of EO they
have a drawbridge underground volcanoes
Cliffs that's it it's quite a hike to
see all of it we're just going to check
out some stuff so many pretty
natural occurrences cuz we're at the
little the little Tippy we were just
saying that you never know where you're
going to find Ino it just seems so
Random Good Old Flower and lamp Museum
there's the
[Music]
lighthouse
YY don't be scared be Daddy's got you
holy whoa what a view
[Music]
wow we're on a little Adventure hike Mar
it's locked in tight don't know what
we're going to
find but definitely spiders no huge
[Music]
one
hey b hey
hey damn you can wiggle yes good morning
it's the next day we're going up the
volcano it looks so
pretty
[Music]
Daren absolutely loved that lift he
didn't cry the whole way at all it's
such a nice calm lift I don't know why
he hated it so
[Music]
much Japan is so packed with beautiful
scenery is
[Music]
crazy
nice we
committed we walked all the way what an
underrated uh place for to view man
Fuji I never heard of this but it's so
good
[Music]
I think this is the last thing you can
see M
Fuji but you can't I have to cross the
road I don't want to do
that did you have a good day beer
oh what
happened still
me
yeah
uhhuh I'm your daddy without
glasses yeah
that's
okay
be careful with
those mhm very funny
right here's the picture from the ski
lift Pi absolutely loved
it he was so
mad they said it was fine I mean people
rote with dogs up there but he just
didn't like it it's so
pretty
[Music]
wow what a great view of M
Fuji we came here hoping to get like a
morning view of Mount
Fuji but the weather said otherwise we
saw it yesterday uh we had some other
plans to do here but I think with a baby
and the rain it's just not a good idea
so we're just going to go to a Christmas
shop that we saw last time we came here
but now it's actually Christmas and beon
will have his first Christmas so we'll
get you something
[Music]
here
we made it no
[Music]
charge